I'd rather lose out on my dream of
buying the Jets than to go IPL I don't
think I'm capable of being a publicly
traded CEO I'd rather be happy in my
freedom day-to-day as a businessman and
miss out on this childhood goal I had
than to compromise my happiness I mean
truth be told if the moment comes in 20
years and there's a quick little I can
sell it and then I can buy the Jets
that's something I'm gonna have to
really talk about the problem is there's
so many videos of me publicly telling
all my employees that the day I sell no
matter what I say you should all resign
so so that would be like maybe not
interesting for someone to buy you know
I won't sell it unless truly the Jets
thing like kind of plays out a certain
way but otherwise you're gonna die yeah
the question you always get asked is you
know what is your exit plan mine's death